I would like to bury the hatchet with  someone I've had issues with I know man  for a long time now you know what I know  Matt so long when I first met Matt I was  the fat one okay Matt what did you think  about Jimmy how did you like working  with Jimmy come on you were the star of  the night  look it's not it's not I I was the one  person who wasn't surprised that it all  got screwed up hey this there's a  mistake moonlight you guys won Best  Picture  [Applause]  it's not a joke this is a very  unfortunate what happened personally I  blame Steve Harvey for this that's what  they get for hiring for hiring Jimmy  they you know you know they got what  they paid for  well sorry Matt but others beg to differ  so what did you think of Kimmel as a  host it's amazing yeah it's good at  everything he does so great he's so  funny we also found out Kimmel got some  support before the show from a certain  Grammy host we have had some emails this  week and I just you know wished him luck  [Music]